I can just imagine like Tommy Robinson
in the far right face like Yes. Yes. Oh,
it's Muslims who've done it. Yes. Who's
the hero? Who's hero? Oh my gosh, he
looks a bit Muslim. Ahmed. No, not
Ahmed. Not Ahmed. It cannot be Ahmed.
His name should not be Ahmed.
Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this brother of ours is
facing. Just 10 minutes ago, he couldn't
stand. Alhamdulillah through your
donations to forever today not only is
he standing but he has a smile on his
face
to each and every one of you who
dignified our brother our father from
donate to forever and help change lives
today
[music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are Inshallah. So
obviously we know about the shooting
that happened in Bondi Beach in
Australia. Um and we are going to
inshallah look at the fact here and also
see the hero cuz no one's speaking about
the hero march. Um and far right
obviously we know these farright dirt
bags who are jumping opportunities. And
the world whole world can see who is
orchestrating or who is allowing these
things to happen and why. We know
exactly why the whole world is woken up
to the reality of Zionism and how their
intelligence and you know um they are
very well connected and they know of
these things going to happen and I
believe it's a conspiracy theory you can
call it they allow it to happen they
know these people they know what they're
about and they stop them when they want
to stop them they let them go when they
want to let them go because it works to
their opport agenda so one of their
shooters obviously we're going to go
through the video inshallah but one of
the shooters is known as um shooters has
been identified as a local Lebanese man
Khaled alsi he traveled from Lambbo to
Bondi and was known to ASIO. Okay.
Australian secret intelligent or forces
if I'm not mistaken. Okay. So now let's
go to some videos and let's see what the
media had to say. Here is one
at the north end today 6:00 or something
like that. Uh the vibe was good but
something just felt off. Uh there was a
big open sort of barbecue happening over
here. Heaps of people around. uh went
and sat on the steps and then all of a
sudden just sound like firecrackers
going off and after about 10:00 uh
everyone just people were running from
here down people were running up
Campbell parade up Hall Street uh I just
started running up Hall Street with a
dog telling people to get in the shops
came down Caris people started running
up Car Lewis it was just pandemonium no
one knew what was going on no one knew
how many shooters there were so um yeah
this this shouldn't happen in Australia
it shouldn't it shouldn't And tell me
what you saw.
>> Oh, just one dead person and it was just
four coppers. That was ages ago before
all the other cops came and just lots of
police and ambulances everywhere.
>> And you saw a person on the ground?
>> Yeah, one or two dead,
>> but there's a lot more.
>> Boss is gone.
>> He took his gun off.
>> We're just going to ask you about the
video you've just watched.
around around the social media obviously
like a lot of videos sending through.
>> We were at a bar mitzvah. I was working
there and there was
>> Okay, so [clears throat] you can see as
you can see they just showed the gunman
um the gunman, two gunmen, one of them
have been um eliminated. Uh the other
one who's been wrestled down by a man.
There is no uh mention of who this man
is, what his name is, but we know he is
a Muslim. I know Tommy Robinson. I know
Paul Golding. I know it's sad news. It's
sad news. You guys do not care about you
was more you get happy. you know this is
the the real they get happy but when
they hear the Muslim now the funny thing
about this is which we're going to go to
actually the uh video the footage of the
man who was injured who tried to save
and rescue these individuals uh before
that we'll go to one other video but the
man himself is Ahmed his name is Ahmed a
Syrian refugee if I'm not mistaken he
put his life on the line now the
question we need to ask is the following
those perpetrators who are committing a
heinous acts against whoever it is for
that matter we don't have any evidence
that it was done because of the Hano the
Jewish festival we don't have any
evidence for that if it was targeting
that okay we do not know we do know that
a Jewish individual was um uh injured
but that doesn't mean the target was
them. We don't know it could be could
not be but there's speculation being
made. However, the question is this
those attackers do they represent Islam
or Ahmed? Is there anywhere in Islam in
any of the literature that says that you
can go out and start hunting innocent
people down? None. Zero. In the Bible it
tells you like the Israelis, the Zionist
what they do in Gaza and what they've
been doing in their scripture clearly
tells us go kill men, women, children,
babies and donkeys. Yes. However, in our
faith, does it say that? Nope. So who
represents us more? Ahmed does.
[clears throat] Cuz the prophetam and in
the Quran Allah says if you save one
soul you have saved the whole of
humanity. That day him putting on his
life he saved tens of people's lives.
And here's a video of him uh injured on
the floor. Let's just watch that in
>> him. The gentleman who raced in to the
scene to disarm one of the gunmen. We're
just learning some details about him
because he has been shot. Now we are
confident in saying that that is him. Uh
he's one of his relatives has just
spoken to one of our reporters. We've
got an interview coming in. We
understand that this gentleman's name is
Ahmed Al Ahmed. He's a 43.
>> I'm just going to stop it there. Yeah. I
can just imagine like Tommy Robinson the
far right face like Yes. Yes. Oh, it's
Muslims who've done it. Yes. Who's the
hero? Who's hero? Who's Who's the hero?
Oh my gosh. He looks a bit Muslim.
Please. Please make his name David
Darren. Uh Luke, Matthew, John. Uh
please just just Ahmed. No, not Ahmed.
Not Ahmed. It cannot be Ahmed. His name
should not be Ahmed. I can just see them
have a meltdown like no, no, the hero is
a Muslim. Yeah. This is how perverted
and how sick in the head these people
are. Let's carry on in
>> old married father of two. Um and he
raced in to help. Uh we understand
apparently owns a fruit shop in
Southerntherland. No experience with
guns. He was just walking past. We are
told that he has two bullets in his arm,
but they think he's going to be okay.
And in the next hour, let's have a
listen to the hero's relatives talking
about his ax this evening at Bondai
Beach.
>> Still, he's in hospital and we don't
know exactly what's going in inside, but
they said the doctor, he's okay. And uh
next two hours, they let us to go in and
see Ahmed because he's still inside in
the he do the operation.
But we hope he will be fine. He's a
hero. 100% he's a hero because what's we
see on the on the on the social media
he's like is 100% hero
>> to his shoulder.
>> Yeah. He have two shots. One in his arm
here and one in his hands.
>> And have you been able to talk to him
today?
>> No. No. because I come when I see the
what's happening and I come here to see
him but they said he's not allowed to go
inside because he have to make operation
whatever I'm still waiting to see him
>> well there you go some firsthand
accounts so in a nutshell guys subhan
Allah obviously we are saddened and very
disturbed and we've been talking about
these individuals extreme views in all
faiths all backgrounds these individuals
who are there attacking innocent people
and It happens to both Muslims to
Christians to Jews and to other faiths
around the world because of these
maniacs. And then we have a
alhamdulillah heroes who come in all
different religions and all the
different backgrounds who come to rescue
individuals. And Ahmed may Allah bless
you because you have done what the
prophetam said you know one of the
lowest form of faith is what to move a
harmful object of the road and this man
was a harmful individual a vile
individual who was targeting innocent
people who are in the be on the beach.
So we thank and we thank u our brother
Ahmed alhamdulillah for saving the lives
of hundreds of people probably cuz if
these guys just carried on in the beach
there were people scattered subhan
Allah. So all we want to say is that
inshallah and it shows that subhan Allah
um that you know we don't we do not know
the ins and outs exactly but what we do
know is that a Muslim hero has come to
the rescue of brother Khaled and put his
life on the line being shot on his arm
and his leg which you can see him on the
floor bleeding and this is what Islam
teaches. So the whole world knows the
truth about Islam. Alhamdulillah, a
Muslim has shown truly what that is. And
those who have an evil agenda, they will
come and say what? Because they have the
same mentality of the shooters. That's
what Islam represents. And those who are
good and have goodness in their heart
will know and say, "No, the true Islam
is the hero who saved the people's
lives, the lives of those people. Let's
see if more news will come up.
Inshallah, that's all I want to say."
And like we said, Allah subhanaa says in
the Quran, if you save one soul, if it's
as if you save the whole of humanity,
subhan Allah. And that is what our
religion teaches. Ahmed, may Allah
protect you and give you shifah.
Brothers and sisters, till next time.